Namco Bandai is getting into the mobile
space with its a new game called
supernova supernova is a MOBA that has
RTS elements realtime strategy you
actually get to build units as your
commanding your commander who is like a
hero or champion like the league of
legends or dota there's not a
traditional like here are free that come
in the three lanes like they normally do
in a traditional MOBA it's here you
build army men or tanks and different
units that try to counter each other it
seems a little bit complex at first but
you do get the ability to like have it
turned on automatically in which case
it's like okay if it builds for you
while you just do your commander portion
it's definitely interesting in the
landscape of MOBAs right now looking at
this I I was taken to another level of
intimidation it is it something that you
feel like is more geared towards people
who really know the genre or is it
something that people could get used to
like could this could be their first
notebook it's more of a hardcore
experience because of all these extra
layers right even myself I was kind of
overwhelmed with all the different
things I had to do like there's so much
more you I going on like there's your
hero abilities and then there's also
abilities that you choose that are like
alliances that is what they call them
that are similar to you know your league
of legends flash your night that are
another set of extra abilities in this
game you can have like a nuke you can
have a heel so those are all extra
things you have to manage and then on
top of that your hero has mastery points
that you then level up only when you're
in your base and that's like another
layer so there's all these different
things to manage and then on top of that
you have to manage or at least be
mindful that you are still building
units or trying to build units even if
it is on autos like I was able to buy I
see like a siege tank or something that
looked like a seed unit to try to push
the lane for others I know that they
said there are going to be tutorials we
didn't get to play those so maybe those
will help kind of integrate playing as a
commander
and trying to build up your army well
the thing that's going to be even more
divisive I I think is that this is a
free-to-play game like most other MOBAs
in a genre and the micro transaction
elements also like other MOBAs are our
cosmetic you can pay to have your
character look different but they're
also going to do some of the abilities
that your character has you can either
pay for with real-world money or use
in-game currency that you earn while
your play they say it's not pay to win
but you never know like until we
actually see how the monetization works
and what you're buying and how those
didn't affect the game like I said
there's so many layers to this game that
until I actually play more or see more I
won't actually know but it's always
scary when you have a free to play game
you never want another player to have an
advantage the mobile space is is pretty
crowded I we've already seen the death
of don Gaetz basically heroes of the
storm isn't in the best position and
everybody's playing dota or league does
this have a chance it does have that RTS
element to it that kind of
differentiates itself from the others
big to mobiles it's such a hardcore
experience that I don't know if there's
enough players it's going to reach and
grab I will say it does look pretty cool
because it's sci-fi there hasn't been
really a sci-fi MOBA so it's got that
for going for it and people are gonna be
able to try it out themselves now the
game has gone into public alpha and
there's no timeline publicly for when
it's gonna you know get a full release
or even the beta but I mean I guess
we'll pretty will hear from a lot of
people very soon since everyone can play
systems
you